quelqu temps j'avais fait une vidéo sur
la Nintendo switch ma toute première
vidéo sur la switch et pour parler de la
switch j'avais un carton alors de l'eau
a couler sur les ponts la console
n'était pas sortie et maintenant elle
est sortie et aujourd'hui c'est à mon
tour te parler de la Nintendo switch et
justement pour en parler qu'est-ce qui a
mieux qu'une Nintendo switch on va donc
aujourd'hui faire un exercice qu'on
appelle unboxing on va regarder ce que c
Nintendo switch dans le
ventre
[Musique]
voilà enfin la Nintendo switch enfin je
peux en parler je suis plus obligé de
faire appel à ça cecitant dit c'était
pas trop mal foutu niveau proportion
regarde je m'en sors pas trop mal au
niveau de mes fakes plus besoin de ça ça
dégage alors regardons voir estce que
c'est console dans le
ventre déjà on t'explique comment ça
marche c'est plutôt pas mal
oh niveau poids je t'assure que c'est
vraiment convenable vu tout ce que j'ai
[Musique]
entendu
console fais voir la languette j'ai
tellement entendu dire que ça languette
était pas terrible ouais ouais c'est
vrai que tu te dis si jamais je tire
trop fort dessus ça risque de péter mais
bon pour l'instant ça va alors le modèle
gris les
joycon ça s'emboîte directement du HDMI
ça c'est pour le doc c'est pour la télé
un chargeur
un ça c'est pour la manette quand tu
mets tes joycon dedans on appuie
derrière on sort les joycon ah il y a
pas à dire la qualité du système est
vraiment génial ça glisse tout seul
c'est top c'est vrai que la position des
doigts un pas d'en haut un pas d'en bas
c'est bizarre après je pense qu'il faut
essayer et qu'il faut s'habituer ah oui
les petits dragon avec les différentes
parties pour pouvoir jouer à de one to
switch par exemple ça c'est le doc tu
vois vraiment que la prise en main de la
console est tout simplement génial c'est
un petit accessoire ça glisse tout seul
alors en réalité derrière pour le
décocher un bouton là et un bouton là tu
appuies sur le bouton tu glisses et ça
glisse vraiment tout seul sur la
glissière tuas un emplacement pour SD
card directement ici l'adaptateur donc
ça pour le charger directement on va en
avoir besoin dans quelques instants ça
c'est pour attacher directement glisse
ça clipe et après il pour le ressortir
normalement j'appuie la manette tu
prends tu glisses tu le fous dedans et
ça marche tout seul voilà donc on a fait
le tour câble HDMI manette écran
derrière avec ça
le chargeur et maintenant il n reste
plus qu'er le charger et aller
jouer bon ça y est la console est finie
de charger maintenant il va être temps
de brancher cette Nintendo switch
Nintendo switch demande là de mettre les
Joy ça
claque yes où est-ce que j'habite en
Europe lisez attentivement les
informations parer console
ok je sais pas si tu es comme moi et que
tu as une clé wifi chiable oh la vache
c'est chiant à faire ça console point
d'accès internet connexion à internet
internet connexion réussie cool Paris
Hamsterdam Bruxelles c'est ça je
confirme connece la console à un
téléviseur afin de profiter d'un plus
grand écran détacher les joycon maintenz
le bouton d'éjection situé à l'arrière
de la manette et tirer vers le haut
plaisir utiliser le stick gauche pour
sélectionner suite en appuyant sur la
touche a avec la mannette droite vous
pouvez utiliser la console avec les JOC
attaché ou détaché choisissez ce qui
vous convient le mieux puis
continuez pass compliquer la tâche
choisissez votre icône et votre surnom
j'ai une bonne tête de donk oh j'ai le
droit 4 10 les boules Monsieur G je vais
m'appeler Bonjour Monsieur j'ai Nintendo
vous permet de créer un environnement de
jeu sûr pour votre enfant grâce au
contrôle parental accessible sur cette
console depuis un appareil connecté ou
il est trop petit je vois pas encore
préparatif terminé le bouton Home est
ici nickel maintenant que la console est
paramétrée il ne me reste plus qu'à
brancher un jeu dedans essayer commencer
à jouer et on va voir ensemble ce que ça
[Musique]
dit maintenant que la console est
installée on va pouvoir la regarder sur
la télé voir comment ça marche parce que
comme ça dans le petit mode c'est
vraiment sympa le mode portable tu peux
effectivement jouer partout maintenant
l'intérêt c'est effectivement de la
mettre directement dessus on va voir
comment ça se branche tu vas voir qu'en
réalité il y a juste deux câbles à
rajouter un câble HDMI pour brancher sur
ta télé et un câble secteur forcément
parce qu'il faut du courant tout en
sachant que le doc que tu as en bas te
permettra effectivement de clipper ta
console dedans pour switcher l'image sur
la télé elle va passer de 720p à 1080p
mais en même temps elle te permettra
effectivement par le biais de la
connectique ici de système de recharge
donc effectivement pendant que tu joues
ça te la recharge pour ton mode mobile
c'est génial
tu vois c'est hyper simple à brancher je
pose ma switch comme ça et hop derrière
tu as deux câbles tu vas retrouver ici
là ton adaptateur secteur ici ton HDMI
l'HDMI se branche directement sur la
télé l'adaptateur secteur directement
sur les prises en bas et ça marche tout
seul une fois que tu l'as clippé là tu
n'as plus qu'à allumer ta télé là hop tu
appuies sur A et on va rentrer
directement dans la console donc là tu
vas qu' réalité en jeu tout de suite
j'ai que one to switch je peux me
balader un petit peu regarder les
différents modes alors les nouvelles
Nintendo eShop les albums photos les
manettes les paramètres de la console et
le mode veille plus mon jeu directement
ici et c'est super bien foutu parce que
la navigation elle est extrêmement
simple donc tu vois en réalité que c'est
une console qui est très facile à
brancher dans le doc qui est extrêmement
simple de prise en main tu as plusieurs
modes de jeu tu as des joycon tu as une
manette tu peux le prendre directement
dans la switch et de barrer avec donc tu
as plein de possibilités et c'est en ça
que cette console est vraiment génial là
elle est connecté directement sur mon
Wii donc il y a pas mal de choses peux
faire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses avec cette console et elle est
vraiment top pour jouer en solo pour J
plusieurs enfin tu vois tu connais le
principe c'est génial franchement je
trouve ça super bien bravo Nintendo je
te ferai une autre vidéo dans laquelle
on parlera d'un peu plus de one switch
parce que je l'ai essayé c'est un jeu
qui est super sympa et tu peux faire pas
mal de choses avec tu V vraiment te
marrer et tu peux te marrer à plusieurs
on enarlera peu plus tard donc là tu
vois que si la console je ve la prendre
et la mettre en mode portable et ben je
ves
dragon
et là c'est génial et c'est tout
l'intérêt de cette console cette console
qui est vraiment formidable j'aies jeux
dessus tu peux aller aux toilettes tu
peux partir au travail tu peux te mettre
dans ta chambre tu fais ce que tu veux
tu joues partout tout le temps top bravo
la Nintendo switch donc voilà pour ce
petit review j'espère que ça t'aura plu
en tout cas cette console je la trouve
vraiment super je vais pouvoir continuer
de l'essayer continuer de m'amuser avec
et puis voir un petit peu ce qu'elle a
dans le ventre merci d'avoir regardé la
vidéo j'espère qu'elle t'a plu dis-moi
en commentaire ce que tu en penses parce
que je pense que maintenant on a fait un
petit peu le tour de la Nintendo switch
et puis on l'a vu un petit peu toutes
les coutures on regardera un peu plus
tard les différents jeux puis notamment
one to switch pour voir un peu que ça
permet comme gameplay que ça permet
comme délire et entre potes je pense
qu'on va bien se marrer dis-moi ce que
tu en penses toi en commentaire n'hésite
pas à regarder cette vidéo là qui est
aussi très sympa abonne-toi à ma chaîne
je te remercie n'oublie pas que si tu VO
toutes les petites notifications et
savoir tout ce qu'il y a sur la chaîne
n'hésite pas à activer la cloche comme
ça dès qu'il y a une vidéo tu seras
averti merci beaucoup et puis je te dis
à très
bientôt y